le parc jean-drapeau deux îles au milieu
du saint laurent
lorsqu'on sort de la station de métro on
ne voit que des arbres et pourtant
cacher derrière il y à montréal le site
changera de visage
montréal québec et la société du parc
jean-drapeau investi 70 millions
on veut avoir une vue imprenable sur la
ville
on va d'abord créer une véritable ali du
métro jusqu'au fleuve la ville et la
sculpture l'homme de calder seront plus
visibles et même si sur ces images il
semble y avoir beaucoup moins d'arbres
on nous assure que le nombre restera le
même c'est une fenêtre magnifique c'est
une carte postale extraordinaire et puis
il y à l'endroit où sont présentés les
spectacles et les festivals comme
osheaga ou et v montréal qui sera
agrandi la capacité d'accueil passera de
45 milles à 65000 personnes
il n'y aura pas de saintes permanente
pas de toi non plus mais on veut
augmenter le nombre de spectacles
présentés ici le maire coderre assure
qu'il ne faut pas s'inquiéter pour le
bruit les produire en plein temps pour
cent puis deuxièmement nous on en fait
des tests de son tout le temps puis
c'est qu'on fait le maire de
saint-lambert sur la rive-sud rappelle
qu'il ya eu soixante deux soirs de
spectacles l'été dernier et des dizaines
de plaintes
il souhaite simplement ne pas être
oubliés des spectacles que d'avoir toute
l'année à tous les soirs messieurs les
mesures de mitigation son remplacent qui
contrôle le sont à la source à la source
le thé se fera pas d'un parc à saint
lambert
les jantes c'est lambert savent que nous
mettons 1,2 millions dans le projet pour
trouver une solution qui va être trouvé
une partie du site sera fermé en 2010
paie en 2018 on devra donc déplacé
ailleurs les événements qui ont lieu
normalement ici on ne sait pas encore à
quel endroit et la société du parc
jean-drapeau assure qu'elle trouvera des
solutions ici france ont permis radio
canada montréal